okay this may the Marvel Universe is
going to change forever in Marvel's
captain america civil war it's Captain
America versus Iron Man going
head-to-head in battles that will span
the globe lines will be drawn as your
favorite heroes have to make impossible
choices whose side will they choose
obviously Captain America i'm pretty
sure you mean Iron Man cap Iron Man Iron
Man cap iron man you know let's just go
behind the scenes of the top secret set
and let them decide it's definitely cab
it's Iron Man side captain america
disney channel on the set goes behind
the scenes of the latest marvel movie
hey we're here on the set of Marvel's
captain america civil war it's all top
secret but I tracked down two of the
movie stars including captain america so
what's the secret that you can talk well
don't know what we can say without
giving too much and I found Robert
Downey jr. to declare my allegiance I'm
a big fan of iron man here will do this
team Tony handshake 30 on Team Tony
hey youtubers is charlie so there's a
civil war behind the scenes teaser it's
it's like the Star Wars Disney Channel
teasers that they posted before episode
7 came out the funniest thing here to me
isn't them trying to get information out
of the actors obviously the actors
aren't going to spill anything from the
movie and in the set by the way the
stuff that they're walking around in is
from the New Avengers facility the one
in upstate New York we haven't seen too
much from the inside of it we really
just got a quick run-through in the
hallways during avengers age of ultron
but it sounds like for at least like the
first act of the film the avengers going
to be a cohesive team so we'll probably
get a lot of scenes inside that building
they probably some pretty cool stuff
usually that's Iron Man's core operating
mission between movies upgrade my toys
speaking of toys look at Robert Downey
jr. and what he is wearing does this not
remind you of the original 21 Jump
Street where you have like this really
old Johnny Depp dressing up like a high
schooler to blend in is like Hot Topic
Tony Stark Robert Downey jr. is like the
most awesome person ever I just love the
idea that he is a child inside he will
forever be a child so I think that's why
he had so much fun making these movies
Chris Evans and Sebastian's stand in
their uniforms without their belts on
actually kind of look like they're
wearing grandpa pants and the funny
thing is is their characters are super
old at this point Bucky did get thought
out several times to assassinate very
high-profile targets but if they kept
brainwashing him then he really didn't
learn about pop culture so I'm guessing
as a Winter Soldier when Steve makes his
list these are all the things that I
need to catch up on Bucky is kind of in
the same place but it's been a couple
movies since then so I mean they they
probably caught up Chris Evans did say
the captain america understood the
internet like he'd been browsing the
internet a lot before age of Ultron more
funny tidbits Chris Evans says that
because he was so sworn to Peggy in his
own heart he's probably still a virgin
he did get to make out quite a bit but
he didn't have sex before he got put on
ice so I'm guessing that they're going
to tease some sort of subtle agent 13
action going on to the background I
don't think that they're really going to
deal with that in this movie because
it's going to be five-alarm chili Iron
Man vs Captain America the whole time
but I know after all the big stuff like
after all the Ultron all the huge stuff
there was the question of the captain
america agent 13 relationship because
it's something that's kind of from the
comics right now in the comics Captain
America is an old man like they found a
way to take the serum out of him last
year in the Falcon became the new
captain america so i think of Captain
America in the comics right now the
Steve
Rogers Captain America is being more
like Nick Fury the teaser does try to
work in that ham-fisted choose your side
mantra really when it comes to picking
aside you have to consider what happened
after civil war in the comics so what
happened after his iron man walked away
seeming like a complete so to
make him more sympathetic Brian Michael
Bendis wrote Mighty Avengers and had
Ultron take over Iron Man's extremists
and basically turned him into a weapon
against his friends somehow I feel like
the movie is going to play with that a
little bit more like I don't think that
Robert Downey jr. would walk into this
movie knowing that he's going to walk
away feeling like a complete
like they're probably gonna make a
little more ambiguous there were a whole
bunch of x-men characters involved in
the comic book lead-up to Civil War so
obviously they're going to change that
so I'm guessing they're going to make a
little bit easier to sympathize with
iron man in this movie but let me know
in the comments even if you haven't read
the comic books Civil War let me know if
your team Iron Man or team cap in
slightly related news there is a
supposed breakdown of Batman V Superman
that I'll totally do a video for
tomorrow so be sure to subscribe to get
that supposedly the european version of
the movie like if you live somewhere in
europe the version of Batman V Superman
that you watch will be longer than the
one in the United States I don't know if
that's true but it sounds like it came
from a legit source so I have to check
it out before I make a video about it
why you guys wait for that video to post
you can click here for all my other
captain america civil war videos and you
can click here for my star wars easter
eggs that i posted earlier today thank
you so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight
you